welcome back to the Rich Eisen show Mike
Doyle 2-fold is a New Jersey item from
Staten Island you remember Crown Heights
in 1980 it was it was an awful time in
the city's history in 1980 when a
teenager got gunned down in the streets
of Flatbush Brooklyn and an 18 year old
kid was arrested and wrongfully
convicted of murder sentenced to life in
prison and a man who plays the lawyer
and childhood friend trying to get the
wrongfully accused out of prison is
sitting right next to me here on the
Rich Eisen show and the movie opens
today in Los Angeles called Crown
Heights opens nationwide next month it's
already won the Audience Award for drama
at this past year's Sundance Film
Festival and the star of that show
happens to be an 11 season veteran of
the National Football League and a
friend Nnamdi awesome walk hello ready
you good to see you so we'll get to your
acting in a moment okay since you're a
thespian I've no ten oh yes thank you
don't like being called back I don't
even you're the first person that I've
ever run yeah thank you for everything
that's right so when you hold up that
gold statuette one day am I in your
speech I will thank you yes will you
really come out because I know you're a
family man I've hosted your foundation
dinner thank you very much you are
despite being as successful as you are
okay the the least successful member of
your family
seriously what we through how many how
many surgeons are there in your family
obviously all of them a lot of a lot of
degrees and just you know I don't so I'm
I'm very when I was like in my eighth
year in the league my mom called and
said when are you going back to school
is that right it's I'm not joking this
is this is real life eight year in the
league Nathan Lee multiple Pro Bowls
under your belt when are you going back
to school now is that when you went to
Philadelphia okay but before filming
before fit yeah see it's he got on me
first so how did you get into football
Namie how did that happen um my brother
my big brother so my dad passed when I
was 12 and my big brother was the guy
that took over I guess that he was 13
and you this is here in Inglewood
California here at the road yeah and so
I just wanted to do whatever he was
doing at that time and that was football
so and I went into football before that
was playing basketball every day of my
life so you played high school football
just up the road here in Inglewood high
school football yep losing your high
school and then Bishop Montgomery High
School and then Narbonne house and then
the Cal Bears reham and then the Cal
Bears I did I noticed a lot of blue and
gold in oh it's the wrong amazing is it
Mays is that what this don't mean to
correct my guests we have similar colors
similar colors you know Kalyn and
Michigan and Cal was the Michigan of the
West when's the last time Cal played
Michigan in football that brockman you
you won that game so you already know
braggadocious unless you're acting using
a thespian skills here who was it who
was on the cow bears nominee when you
were there
our quarterback was Kyle Boller who
played with the Ravens a few different
teams and you know Andre Carter was on
the team dealt O'Neil hmm you know some
NFL guys yeah and then you get the call
from Al Davis one day that happened get
the call from Al Davis he's walked me
through what Nnamdi awesome
was that like when Al Davis called you I
lived in the dorms all four years at Cal
at Cal all for you what about that why
did you do that all four years because
everything was paid for everything was
taken care of you know I know that you
if you live off campus you can you know
you get a little a little bit of money
but it was right there I'm a kind of
minimalist so so so I lived on campus so
I was in my dorm then I got the phone
call from it wasn't al know was out was
a DD location
Aloka sell it what did you pull look I
can't believe you now I'm the I am a
professional well done well network guy
yeah I've been on the business end of
somehow moments myself so but please
walk me through it was it Lombardi was
it Lambo maybe called you up you know
what's weird and this is this is
terrible
I don't remember okay exactly who it was
so it was just some stooge it was some
in the old days a load flow chart yeah
and they said oh we're taking you with
the 31st pick and in my room was it was
me my brother and one of my sister's was
in my room and we just all started you
know jumping up now and going cray and
then at that point because you know
you're watching it on TV and everybody
can see it
once they called my name people flooded
into my you know there was just you're
the most popular guy that does not not
stop people coming into the dorms
obviously a bunch of freshmen but it was
still you know still so when did I'll
get on the horn you I mean that you've
got to remember that right when al
called you like the voice the Godfather
getting on the phone welcome to the res
I was just only senior that was still in
[Laughter]
but by that point were you buying kids
beers or you don't know listen by that
point as the only senior in the dorms
yes I had like big as the RA at least I
had the biggest suite
I had like had my own like washer/dryer
I ran the place it was great it was
great man it was great don't make me
feel self-conscious no no no you're
winning okay okay nom-a-nom be awesome
while you're winning life right now
like so it was a step down going to the
pros in other words with your living
situation
your first professional contract you
were like bit of a step down it was it
was but I survived I can't remember one
out when I spoke to Al the first time
hmm
I can't and it it might have been my
first practice he was elusive like that
I might have been my first prey and
what'd he say
what he said you remember that I've one
of the first conversations I remember us
having was we want you to move to corner
and he and I and he stated it before he
asked me if I wanted to do so obviously
the answer that it was basically we want
you to move to corner would you like to
move to corner and of course he
pronounced it corner right corner yeah
yeah and it was you know it was an
interesting moment I wanted to play
safety my god I was begging to play
safety and he said no I see you as a
corner again it worked out I mean you
get paid better at corner too than its
safety Nnamdi yeah you know yes yes
that's what I understand you you have a
higher standard
see now I'm self-conscious we're sitting
here making each other self-conscious
norm by the way let's get together and
make a movie about this this is an idea
about a senior living in the freshman
dorms
yeah what's called Van Wilder we're back
in 60 seconds with Nnamdi awesome one
we'll talk a little bit more football
into your acting career and everything
going on with a back in sixty Seconds
here on the Rich Eisen show
oh my gosh I mean talk about with Nnamdi
Asomugha who's here in studio from the
Raiders - and I do want to hit the
Philadelphia moment in your career
before we then move on to your acting
career and everything going on with you
right but Mike tell Tufo cuz you
mentioned in the previous segment you
lived in the freshman dorm all four
years at Cal Berkeley you got the call
from the Raiders that you found out you
were drafted as a first round draft
choice well I was in in the dorms that's
right
and then you yes seat hall I was in the
we were in the corner room I was at I
think I was 24 just during 24 year old
man and the freshman doing it and I was
living there illegally third roommate
with two other because it was jugular
room was gigantic he gets it yeah that's
it I mean what what you don't move
what's that you don't all right there it
is the penthouse yeah you know I don't
leave I had a suite you can get the food
you know you drop your own shower right
down there the food is made your own
shower in your room yeah of course don't
look at me like that cuz when I think
about dorm life no no more like the
white shadow you know you're all singing
in the shower with a bunch of other
people you know I think more happier so
not me awesome well here on the Rich
Eisen show so when you went to
Philadelphia yeah I'm a cuz I remember
this like it was playing it just skipped
Oakland before the break you said I'm
threatening you
passive-aggressively moving the corner
which only worked out to the tune of
multiple Pro Bowls in a fat large
multi-million dollar contract now you
want me to skip Oakland now you so now
you go to Philadelphia and you signed
free agent there what was it like when
you heard Vince Young drop the dream
team what was that like I didn't hear it
I didn't hear him
I didn't hear we heard it from other
people like I turned into thing and I
don't even know if he said it I feel
like it was asked to him or something
and then he said yes or I don't even it
was is this like the dream team and he
goes yeah
dream team but you know who kind of
started that it was my one of my
favorite coaches of all time and he told
me this recently Rob Ryan he said he was
being interviewed I think he was with
the Cowboys and like we had just started
and everybody had signed I think he said
super Timor dream team or something and
then he said that's when it came to
Vince Young maybe he's just trying to
take credit for it but I don't know I'll
be odd that Rob Ryan would be boisterous
in any way it's a lot of counters that
okay for all the Ryan's yeah oh dream
team that was it right there
yeah Vince all that was it yeah that's
the first time I've ever heard that it's
absolutely the first would you like to
hear it again plenty o dream team the
laugh after is my favorite part and what
what made him like I'm short
I mean you cut out the question that
came before that yeah have you not met
the sports media before yeah exactly
we roll yeah so you never heard that
before until now I hadn't no cuz it did
it cuz the we don't think about it no it
was like we had so much going on because
we all came in at a time where I think
the moment we the moment like they
lifted the lockout you we had like 18
hours or something everybody jump on a
team crazy you know you're not flying
out anywhere so you're not taking trips
it's just like make a call make it
happen and I think when we got there we
played it we had a preseason game like
three days later and nobody knew
anybody's names he you know I mean like
it was just trying to gel and so I think
that that whole thing was the least of
our concerns why didn't it work it's
probably a ton of reasons I think
anytime you bring that much talent to a
team it's got to work in a cohesive
sort of way and I think we had a lot to
learn I think we couldn't pick it up but
and me specifically like I couldn't I
wasn't necessarily on page with a lot of
what was being asked and you know just
couldn't really pick it up fast enough
now I'm the awesome one here in the Rich
Eisen show and we we were in a way
joking but it really is no joke you your
family is filled with surgeons brain
surgeons as well if I'm not mistaken
correct no there's no the brain the
freezer in the fan no no but I for some
reason that was stuck in my head
but in all seriousness tapping out on
your playing career early okay by
retiring as you did at age 32 was there
any concern about ZTE and anything else
that obviously has come more to the
force since you have you know it's crazy
NFL there was I didn't I was never
concerned with CTE until I saw the movie
concussion no kidding yeah I never even
really thought of it in that sort of way
and then I saw that movie and that's
when the big media storm about it really
happened at least from my perspective
and then the concern definitely was
there do you have any effects at all
ever no no I know I mean I think about
it but I don't think I have any effects
just yeah I mean I played a lot of
safety in college and in high school so
I do have those thoughts like I wonder
if you know down the line because of all
the baying something you know could
happen but you know I don't know it's
tough when you hear about guys like Tony
Dorsett and other guys that are dealing
with stuff because then you it's a real
thing let's talk about your acting
career I we had fun on our podcast years
ago cuz you were on Friday Night Lights
and remember I saw that I'm like that's
Nami awesome ah in Friday Night Lights
that's right is that where you got the
acting bug
essentially I think that I think a lot
of it came from there but I was also I
always thought about acting and so I was
always like really appreciative of good
acting ever since I was a little kid
okay and I'll never forget like I
thought about doing it and then I was at
we were in spring football or something
that
the team that I think beat Michigan the
last time those two played eachother
we've got that information if we can
hold it honestly I don't even know if
you were free and born that by the time
we got better since then
yeah but the we were so we were in
spring football and a buddy of mine that
was on the team you know our big you
know linebackers he said you know hey
guys I want to I'm doing a play if you
guys can come down check me out you know
it's gonna be on campus next week or and
I was the ringleader for like making fun
of him like ah he's gonna do a play look
at this guy
you know I was doing that whole thing
and finally I got some guys together we
all went down to see his play and he
just he blew me away
hmm was actually completely real and
truthful and great and it was that was
one of the moments I was like okay you
know this is it's actually a cool thing
you know I I shouldn't I can embrace it
you know well real truthful and great
can definitely describe Crown Heights
that you are in why this project how did
you get involved with that just nandi I
just I was reaching out to directors and
just trying to listen you can't play
football forever like you know I have to
move on in a in like a kind of a quick
way so I was just reaching out to
directors trying to see if I could
audition for something and this story
came and I asked for the script and I
asked if I could audition and our
director Matt Ruskin let me audition
maybe a month later and I got the part
and that was it and how did you I mean
you kind of transform yourself I mean
just sound like you've got an accent
accent yeah I I mean I I spent there
real guys yeah and they're from Trinidad
so I spent time with them so I had to
learn or you know learn as much of an
accent as I could in the time that we
had and it was really great to spend
time with him it's the whole the whole
story of what they went through and and
coming out on the other side and just
forgiving everybody I thought it was
like just remarkable and you know did
you meet Colin Warner they can't make
huh yeah 20 years in prison right yeah
21 years in prison for some
he didn't do and you met him met him
we're actually really close now me you
know our families and Carl King the man
that I play yeah absolutely he wasn't a
lawyer he was just a regular friend and
he he learned the legal system just said
he could get his friend out it took him
21 years what a story
it's crazy what a story really just
makes you think it I do remember in 1980
when this will happen
yeah yeah with Crown Heights and and
then what you were in I was in Staten
Island New York I lived there at eleven
years right as eleven years old just
like watching the news and just seeing
how you see the towers from your house
no you couldn't no I was actually in
Connecticut when they when they fell but
in terms of the towers I always saw them
from a certain part of stand on taking
the ferry right boys just take the ferry
to go to New York City got it yeah
so how many kids do you have 3 okay I've
got a 10 month old at home I was a 10
month old that's food and you're acting
you're flying all over the place I know
your husband this is this is life life
goes on I could not be happier for you
an awesome wha F and DN is still your
Twitter handle because your foundation
that's the foundation yeah so how can
people get involved with your foundation
yeah you could you could go to our
website building today org there's tons
of ways to get involved there donate
help out volunteer and then yet Twitter
it's SM wah and DN and tomorrow there's
a QA for this film yeah correct yeah
we're doing a QA my wife and I are doing
a QA at Arclight in Hollywood yes um
after the 7 p.m. show and then also at
raves cinemas in Baldwin Hills and after
the 8:30 p.m. show and you know so it's
you Kerry Washington an arc like
Hollywood and Baldwin Hills and the DVD
monitor and TBD moderator which again I
can always help you on that don't forget
that's right and then there's at AMC
Century City Tony Goldwyn ed and Tony
Goldwyn is doing one with our director
and with the real Colin Warner at am
City my century SID AMC century's Yeti
that's what's going down
you know Tony's been on the show a
couple times he's been on the show he's
a great guy he's a great guy you don't
have a problem with Tony Goldwyn
I don't have a problem with Tony go to
it no not at all I don't have the trust
you don't want to throw it in with Tony
go one no no see you're an actor you
understand have an active is a
difference between professionalism and
you've acted before excuse me is that
good is me excuse me
Nate may I bring up once again the
residual check I just received for
playing announcer and the CSI Miami
episode called caged received a $2 and
$0.33 check hashtag suck at Caruso for
it was announcer was the was your
character's name announcer announcer
announcer it was I don't know why oh you
know it's my credited role that was the
credit yeah well then and just all I
know is look at me today I know you've
listened your pocket square let me ask
you a question yes sir sports question
yeah what's the one we have we have
YouTube now so you can you know you can
watch really what's the one sports play
in the history of sports that you can
watch over and over and over again and
it'll always give you goosebumps um
great questions hey I was just thinking
of it you know what can you want to
stick around one more star we gonna come
back to that sometimes what we've got is
what we call a commercial break in the
business yeah that's right I've got a
patient bills okay for the television
audience you will see my acting ability
because I'm in the Katy Perry music
video hello excuse me hello the hashtag
suck it DP suck it all rows little of it
your role was male interviewer so don't
don't don't tell congratulate hashtag
I'm just reading what it says
we're back with naam the awesome Oracle
question yes up for our three with that
question
we're back with morning Nnamdi Asomugha
a longtime national football league
player of notes and also one of the
stars of crown heights at IFC film that
is in Los Angeles today opens nationwide
next month on Friday September 15th one
more segment you asked before going wait
deef still run the 40 damn straight you
do okay oh yeah oh yeah I do you do know
I know you're in the the world of
Tinseltown now you go to the Vanity Fair
parties I understand that you know I see
you there it's no you understand it's my
side of the story yes that you got no no
I still I said you were saying towards
the end of the last segment like what is
that one moment that you see on YouTube
that gives you goosebumps that's right
what is that one for you that every time
you see it it gives you goosebumps I can
see it a million straight time which is
Kirk Gibson that homerun for the Dodgers
the home run and the Vin Scully call -
and then the call on Eckersley I can see
it a million times
goosebumps oh my god that's it and they
season that the what the what was the
the improbable has happened here in the
year the impossible the problem was
something or probably impossible has
happened
let's just keep watching Vince long
without yeah no it's okay don't worry
del two folks not gonna nail it for me
for me I got it's got its money that you
know your football guy I'm a football
guy are you gonna base by I am at Reggie
Jackson's third home run against the
Dodgers 1977 Wow or Chris Chambliss is
home run against the Royals to put the
Yankees in the World Series do you have
that one Mike Dell to foe
[Applause]
nice punch yeah where is that yeah yeah
here comes it's come VIN just sits there
and lets the crowd go it's quite a hang
time long enough for me to say that
Crown Heights is in theaters near you
today in Los Angeles well then and next
month September 15th nationwide Michigan
last played Cal in 1980 Michigan 38
Catherine yeah it's been a while
Cal 38 no no Mazen blue 38 mystery in
colors 13 is it to see you Nnamdi please
come back anytime don't be a stranger
okay Congrats on everything that's
happening to you it is so beyond
deserved only only gonna get better and
I'd love to love to have you here again
thank you thank god this is great
everybody check out Crown Heights in a
theater in Los Angeles today and
nationwide next month Larry Merchant in
studio we come back the Rich Eisen show
weekdays at noon eastern on radio
stations across the country and audience
if you liked that video be sure to
download our app don't have any memory
on your phone let's start to delete some
of those slo-mo videos you have and you
know which ones I'm talking about